we've got everything that we need on the  planet at this time but we just need to  be able to cooperate at scale creating  che truly decentralized peer to peer  distributed planetary operation system  the wealth disparity is the greatest  it's ever been in history and it's only  going to increase with automation until  we have a different set of systems that  actually create different incentives  competition still and scarcity and  really this planet has everything that  we need and we just don't have the right  infrastructure yet as I have allowed my  own feminine to flourish and to not be  shamed my masculine has actually gotten  even stronger and when I looked at  different religions and ancient  civilizations that there was a common  thread through many of them  [Music]